[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now
or next our media group we're hoping
we're going to be able to have those
very meaningful and productive
conversations
tonight on politics now can democrats
and republicans work together in carson
city
hear from both sides on their budget
priorities as the session gets underway
plus we ask get nevada back to work
and the kids back in the school what
roles schools and economic development
will play in this legislative session
and a spike in student suicides the
ideas on how to try and turn around a
growing problem
eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us on
politics now i'm john langley the nevada
legislative session is officially
underway
several major issues need to be tackled
but first all lawmakers and staff were
tested for the coronavirus before they
went into the capitol
earlier this week new lawmakers were
sworn in leadership positions named
democratic assembly speaker jason
fryerson and senate leader nicole
cannizzaro are staying in their
positions
the topic looming over the entire
session is the budget
how can lawmakers pay for state services
with such a drop in tax revenue
whether it's social justice or you know
revenue
i i think that we're going to have to
deal with those and struggle through
some of those
areas where we might not agree um but
also be willing to find some common
ground and compromises
we have a very antiquated
tax system and a very complicated tax
system
do we need to have an overview of the
nevada tax system
absolutely democrats will need to
compromise if they want to raise taxes
they lost their super majority in the
legislature back in november
that means democrats need some
republicans to vote with them to raise
revenue
the i-team's david charns was up in
carson city for the start of the session
joins us here now
to talk about some of the priorities up
in carson city david
what are they saying about where this
money is going to come from well
certainly at the start of the session it
was sort of this very kumbaya feel but
i asked senate majority leader nicole
canezzaro where the money will come from
and i asked her some other questions as
well
here's what she said this is probably a
tough session because we have a budget
to find money for
um you know we have social services
education
roads all this to fund and obviously the
pandemic has
um limited some of that income so what
are some ways
that we're going to be able to find
compromise in the senate
i think the first and foremost piece of
that is that we really do have to work
together
we have to work together as a
legislative body for the betterment of
the state
and so i of course again remain hopeful
that we're going to be able to find a
way to do that
but with respect to the budget concerns
i think it's going to mean that we're
going to spend a lot of time
looking at each and every budget
decision to make sure that we're doing
everything we can
to keep those vital services for
nevadans and to help move the state
out of our economic
situation and into a better place right
so those budget decisions are going to
be so important
additionally we're going to keep all
options on the table in terms of revenue
we're of course always hopeful that the
federal government is going to help come
in and support states like nevada
there's some discussion from
your republican colleagues about looking
at
executive power and making it more of a
bipartisan solution
um you know i the discussion is well
why are we in a state of emergency for
10 months um i think you and i
know why i mean we're wearing masks but
they say you know it's not necessarily
about our current governor
but in governors in in future situations
is that something that you want to look
at as well i will say this
we are still in a state of emergency 10
minutes into this pandemic
because we are still in the middle of a
global pandemic we still are seeing
that hospitals are struggling to make
sure that they can keep up
with taking care of everyone who walks
in their doors whether they be there
because of a cove diagnosis
or for some other medical treatment we
know that there are still people who are
dying from this disease and families who
are losing family members
so until we're out of a pandemic we're
still in the middle of the emergency
which necessitated
the declaration of emergency does
anything change now that
democrats lost seats in that there is
more bipartisanship that needs to happen
than in years past does that change
anything for you
so in the senate we're actually a
one-seat difference um so i don't know
that it has changed too much
from our standpoint um and we've always
endeavored to work in a bipartisan
fashion
i think if you actually take a look at
the bills that we pass that doesn't mean
we always agree on everything right that
doesn't mean
we're all a hundred percent because we
all represent different constituencies
we all come with different viewpoints
and we have sometimes different things
that we're advocating for
but the one thing that i think we've
always been able to do is to sit down
and talk about those differences
and for the most part we tend to agree
and we tend to find the path forward
to make nevada better kumbaya indeed
david
so in that interview you asked senator
cannizzaro about trying to
limit emergency powers several
republicans have talked about that in
the last month is that still going to be
a priority now that the session is
underway
yeah so it really does seem like it is
certainly one of their priorities john
and then certainly another one
that they have to do every time is the
budget now i asked republican assembly
floor leader
dr robin titus about this as well and
here's what she said about that
we have to get nevada back to work and
the kids back in the schools
and that has to be a priority without
question on that we have we met saturday
at the caucus we have a list of
priorities that we'll be sending out and
things that we go on to work on
bills that we'll be introducing but back
to work back to school how excited are
you to get this session underway
um very excited i think there's things
and problems that need to be solved
our state and our obviously the nation
wants to see somebody somewhere do
something good and work together
i think we can do that here in nevada
you may want to look at
some executive power provisions how much
power the governor has to close
the state election security things are
you going to entertain that well that is
one of our priorities
defining the executive branch
emergency orders what is that role
it's not about the governor it's not
about this governor it's about
what an nrs we need clarification on nrs
nobody anticipated an extended emergency
this isn't just you know when you have
an emergency we've had flooding before
you know we've had
crisis before nowhere in our ns defines
an extended emergency so we need
clarification i think that can be a
bipartisan
ask did that governor er in his power in
any way
was did he overstep by looking at it i
think the governor did what the governor
felt he had the right to do
because there's no other direction and i
think that's what we need
definition so is this currently there's
no rules that say otherwise
has democratic leadership reach up to
you at all about tax increases or
tax deals at all interesting the
democrats have not reached out to us to
say
what taxes would you be willing to
support they have
in their in the governor's state of the
state that he did not mention any tax
increases
leadership has not reached out and said
hey we have some this is we're really
going to need to do this
what's the possibility so they may say
that oh well you know it takes people at
the table but they have not reached out
to say what's a reasonable discussion
so that bill is written ab93 is the
number
is written by republican assemblyman jim
wheeler and it would end a state of
emergency after 15 days unless the
legislature
actually votes to approve it interesting
so so david again there's sort of a
there's broadly a positive vibe it seems
like early on in the legislative session
but there
has already been a little bit of
controversy new republican assembly
woman annie black
stirred some controversy up she was in
washington d.c january 6
at the trump rally yeah so she was there
she was at the rally part of all those
you know what was going on that day she
didn't go in the capitol building
some democrats had called for her to
resign but she told me that on day one
she was actually being welcomed
with open arms they respect my
first amendment rights free speech and i
didn't break any laws so
that's what they're telling me that's so
that's all i know
now there was also a little work that
got underway this week since the start
of the pandemic of course
20 clark county school district students
have died by suicide now this new law to
be debated this session would require
school districts have a pandemic plan
and also a plan to deal with suicide as
part of their emergency procedures
the nevada department of education
actually requested lawmakers
to talk about the spill and lawmakers on
both sides say
this is certainly critical interaction
and that critical interaction between
students and teachers is really key
they're going to have that interaction
with their teacher teachers and others
are mandatory reporters they see what's
going on
they can ask questions they can see if
there's something troubling a student
if something has changed in their lives
for all different reasons
kids get down and get disconnected
and so we just need to make sure that we
have all the resources that we
absolutely can provide from every entity
and every group so that these kids have
support now they also want to see if
there's any trend between students who
had
access to in-person learning and those
who did not john
david a very important issue across the
state of nevada appreciate that sir
now another bill being debated up in
carson city would let police officers
sue members of the public assembly bill
92 was introduced by republican
assemblyman jim wheeler
it would allow a peace officer to sue
someone who injured them
prevented them from doing their job or
filed a false complaint
a first hearing has not yet been
scheduled on tuesday clark county
commissioners picked two new members of
the state legislature
public health worker democrat fabian
donate now represents
state senate district 10. he said on
twitter he is
excited to fight for public health and
improving the lives of all nevadans
donate replaces ivana kinsella who
joined the biden administration
tracy brown may is the new assemblywoman
for district 42.
she is director of advocacy board and
government relations over at opportunity
village
she replaces alex asepha who resigned
amid a campaign finance scandal
next on politics now republicans versus
big tech
the sections of u.s law that shield tech
companies from those lawsuits
our vanessa murphy looks into what would
actually happen if it was repealed plus
i'm alexandra limoni in washington
coming up we'll take a look at president
biden's immigration policies
and why it will likely be very difficult
for the administration to reunite
immigrant families
welcome back to politics now
president joe biden has signed an
executive order aimed at reuniting
families separated at the border
a task force a federal task force will
try and find those parents at least 650s
parents were separated from their
children and deported to
mexico and central america local
immigration advocates applauded the
decision
making sure that he's actually keeping
promises that he made
during the campaign trail and i think
that's very very important
i think one of the most important
policies for me right now is the fact
that he is going to develop
that task force to make sure that he's
reuniting those families that were
actually separated
over under the trump administration
president joe biden has made immigration
a top priority he has signed a whole
bunch of executive orders on that issue
sending a proposed bill to congress
we're joined now as you can see there by
our washington correspondent alexander
limon
to break down what the president's done
so far uh let's let's get started here
alex what have we seen from the white
house
we saw president biden initially on his
very first day in office signed some
executive orders but this week he
actually signed
additional executive orders on
immigration
and when he was signing them this week
he said you know i'm not making
new policy here i'm just eliminating bad
policy
and what he means is that by and large
all of these immigration executive
orders
basically simply undo the hard-line
immigration policies that we saw
enacted under president trump also via
executive order
so some of the newest orders that were
signed by biden this week for example
address or at least order various
departments to take a look at
you know how people are applying for
asylum and visas
and green cards and even citizenship
because under the trump administration
we did see all of those processes become
much more difficult
and much more expensive and it was just
you know slowly becoming harder and
harder for people to apply for
you know legal entry into the united
states can we expect any additional
actions on immigration from the
president these seem to be measures more
to sort of uh reverse what the former
president did
the trump administration what about
moving forward so there's a couple of
things that could happen we could see
more executive orders from president
biden
particularly on the issue of the use of
for-profit immigration detention centers
this is something that
president biden during the campaign had
promised he would eliminate the use of
these private for-profit centers
immigration detention centers and we
actually already saw biden take action
when it comes to
private prisons and directing the doj
to eliminate and phase out the contracts
with private for-profit
prisons and that was alexander limon
from washington d.c
next on politics now republicans versus
big tech
does not only protect big tech
it protects tiny websites it protects
users like you and me
the gop takes aim at laws protecting
tech
companies from lawsuits the itunes
vanessa murphy looks into the issue plus
we look at two notable deaths in nevada
politics this week on politics now
[Music]
you're watching politics now
republicans have been targeting tech
companies recently
claiming conservatives are being
unfairly censored they've set their
sights on a law known as section 230 and
have pushed to repeal it
essentially section 230 protects tech
companies like facebook and twitter from
legal liability for what users post
there
vanessa murphy spoke with noted first
amendment attorney ari cohn
who handles section 230 issues and
breaks it all down
i think the easiest simplest way to
explain
section 230 is
the people who are liable for things on
the internet
are the people who created those things
on the internet
what section 230 does is it prevents
me safe from holding twitter liable for
something that somebody else posted
among other things
it also protects users if i retweet
something that is defamatory
uh the original author of the tweet has
to be soon
not me uh but it's also important to
remember and this gets lost in a lot of
the shuffle is that
much of what section 230 protects
is stuff that the first amender protects
anyways
the a lot of the lawsuits you see for
content moderation
for banning users and things like that
those would
be dismissed on first amendment grounds
anyways eventually just with a lot
greater time and expense
it's just a shortcut for the courts but
getting rid of section 230 doesn't mean
that twitter couldn't ban donald trump
it doesn't mean that it can't moderate
content that it finds objectionable
all it would do is me it would cost
twitter a little bit more to defend
against the lawsuits
it simply says twitter or facebook or
any website or
any facebook for that matter is not the
publisher of things that users post
that's it no more no less 2020
2021 it becomes the center of this
political argument what can you say
about that
in the the current political climate
what you have is two sets of arguments
you have the argument that social media
companies
aren't doing enough to remove harmful
content generally speaking
most people perceive this as coming from
the left side of the political spectrum
and then you have the people perceived
on the right side of the spectrum
who say social media companies are
discriminating against conservatives
they're banning users they're removing
content and they should lose this
protection as a result of them not being
open to all voices
so when you're talking about that side
that right side of the spectrum when it
comes to content moderation
again the thing that you have to
remember is these decisions are
protected by the first amendment
social media companies could do them one
way or the other
whether section 230 existed or not so if
i'm
your average joe on facebook on twitter
or posting a review on amazon for a
product
the way it stands right now what does
this all mean for me
well if section 230 cease to exist
tomorrow
there's two things that could happen uh
one thing that could happen is
companies on the internet could just say
we're not going to moderate anymore
throw their hands up in the air and say
it's not worth the risk
then you end up with an internet that is
so full of garbage
that nobody wants to do anything about
that it becomes
so much so much more unusable than it
can already be at times
if they decide to moderate what's going
to happen is they're going to over
moderate
they're going to take things in moderate
to high heavens
and you might see delays in your posts
going up or you might just see things
being taken down
at astonishing rates i mean if they
decide to tighten up the
machine learning and ai content
moderation controls
and say be even more over cautious uh
you know you could see a whole bunch of
stuff just getting taken down
perhaps even without a human ever
looking at it
just because the uh the motivation will
be to avoid liability
there won't be a motivation to do it
well there'll be a motivation to do it
well enough
that they don't get sued section 230 was
passed as part of the communications
decency act in 1996
it was amended in 2008 to require the
removal of material that violates
federal and state sex
trafficking laws in other political news
there were two notable deaths
unfortunately in the nevada political
world this week
longtime las vegas political political
consultant dan hart
passed away he was 66 years old friends
say he died of a heart attack tuesday
night
hart started by working on the campaigns
of democrats like former las vegas mayor
jan jones back in the 90s
more recently he worked on ballot
initiative campaigns for the nevada
state education association one of the
big teachers unions
second amendment advocate don turner
also passed away this week
turner was president of the nevada
firearms coalition he lost a long battle
with cancer on
monday he was one of the strongest
lobbying voices for the gun rights
community here in nevada
next on politics now changing the name
the latest push to remove
former nevada senator pat mccarron's
name from mccarran airport next on
politics now
you're watching politics now
the nevada state democratic party has to
pick a new chairperson
current chairman william mccurdy the
second says he's not running again
mccurdy is now in the clark county
commission says he wants to focus on
that job instead
nevada democrats will pick new
leadership march 6.
democratic clark county commissioner
tick sega bloom is pushing once again to
rename mccarran international airport
after former senator harry reid seger
bloom tried this four years ago up in
the legislature but it failed
right now he's on the clark county
commission and he has a couple of other
commissioners backing him as well
former senator mccarran was has often
been criticized for his anti-semitic
views and actions when he served
the faa would still have to sign off on
any new name if clark county decides to
change it
now we did an unscientific twitter poll
to ask your opinion
more than 830 of you voted and 26
percent of you agreed to change the name
74 percent disagreed
this week in what to watch the start of
former president donald trump's
impeachment trial is starting
opening arguments in the senate trial
begin next week at this point the former
president
is not expected to testify in person
some senators are also pushing for a
potential
censure of the former president instead
of impeachment
and the nevada legislature continues
budget hearings are underway for state
agencies we are keeping an eye on to see
what is going to get cut
in order to help them meet their budgets
thank you very much for watching
politics now this week stay up to date
online and watch us every saturday take
care
[Music]
you